after a surge in fighting in recent
weeks the UN's acting Special
Representative Stephanie Williams gave
this bleak assessment of the situation
in Libya to Security Council ambassadors
I believe we have reached another
turning point in the conflict conflict
from what we are witnessing in terms of
the massive influx of weaponry equipment
and mercenaries to the two sides the
only conclusion that we can draw is that
this war will intensify broaden and
deepen with devastating consequences for
the Libyan people as the foreign
intervention increases the Libyans
themselves are getting lost in the mix
their voices crowded out we must not let
Libya slip away she said it was
civilians paying the price 58 killed and
a hundred and ninety injured since the
1st of April an 89 percent rise in
civilian casualties compared with the
first three months of the year she said
the vast majority were the result of
attacks by general half-days forces she
said it was regrettable that at the end
of April the general had rejected the
international peace plan and claimed he
alone had a mandate to rule the country
Libya's ambassador who's loyal to the
government of national Accord was
scathing about after and one of his main
international backers the United Arab
Emirates we wish to inform you or inform
this council that we have damning
evidence of direct illegal transfer of
these specific weapons to Libya by the
United Arab Emirates in support of the
war criminal and his militias which
these evidence we are sharing with the
panel of experts in previous Security
Council meetings over years the United
Nations has been reluctant to criticize
one side or the other simply saying that
both must show restraint but the tone
has now changed the criticism of general
hafter was direct and much stronger amid
reports that even some of his backers
believe the impetuous commander
has overplayed his hand James BAE's
al-jazeera
at the United Nations